I'm going to walk around to see if
anyone will give me $50 to find out
what's inside this blue
envelope oh you
almost I saw this couple and decided to
see if they'd bite would you like to
give me $50 to find out what's inside
this do you take I don't want your money
but you can look and see what you guys
just upgraded to when they opened it
they could not believe what was inside
what they found was two VIP experiences
for the NBA in season tournament first
we sawo at the set to see what the guys
were up to nonsense as usual then we
headed inside to the VIP hospitality
room here they could eat and drink until
they exploded and they also got to talk
to NBA legends like Gary Payton and
Julius Irving oh did I mention the view
then it was time to head to their floor
seats before sitting down they were able
to see Shack I mean he's pretty hard to
miss then it was game time and they got
to enjoy it sitting in some of the best
seats in the House definitely an
upgraded day